we're entering the third week of illegal
blockades that have been disrupting the
lives of too many canadians
here in our capital city
families small businesses have been
enduring illegal obstruction of their
neighborhoods
occupying streets
harassing people breaking the law
this is not
a peaceful protest
at the borders in different parts of the
country the blockades are harming our
economy and endangering public safety
critical supply chains have been
disrupted
this is hurting workers who rely on
these jobs to feed their families
yesterday the ambassador bridge was
reopened between windsor and detroit
our team and i have been working with
ontario and the city of windsor around
the clock i want to thank the officers
on the ground including the rcmp who
played an active role
we now have a responsibility to make
sure
that the bridge stays open
with each illegal blockade
local law enforcement agencies have been
acting to keep the peace within their
jurisdiction
despite their best efforts
it is now clear that there are serious
challenges to law enforcement's ability
to effectively enforce the law
on friday ontario invoked a state of
emergency to respond to the blockades
this was the responsible
and necessary thing to do
today
to continue building on these efforts
the federal government is ready to use
more tools at its disposal to get the
situation fully under control
after discussing
with cabinet and caucus
after consultation
with premiers from all provinces and
territories
after speaking with opposition leaders
the federal government
has invoked the emergencies act
to supplement provincial and territorial
capacity
to address the blockades
and occupations
i want to be very clear
the scope of these measures will be time
limited
geographically targeted
as well as reasonable
and proportionate
to the threats they are meant to address
the emergencies act will be used to
strengthen and support law enforcement
agencies
at all levels across the country
this is about keeping canadians safe
protecting people's jobs
and restoring confidence in our
institutions
here's how the measures we're taking
today
will help get the situation under
control
the police will be given more tools to
restore order in places where public
assemblies can constitute illegal and
dangerous activities such as blockades
and occupations as seen in ottawa the
ambassador bridge and elsewhere
these tools include strengthening their
ability to impose fines
or
imprisonment the government will
designate secure and protect places and
infrastructure that are critical to our
economy and people's jobs including
border crossings and airports
we cannot
and will not allow illegal
and dangerous activities to continue
the emergencies act will also allow the
government to make sure essential
services are rendered for example in
order to tow vehicles walking roads
in addition financial institutions will
be authorized or directed to render
essential services to help address the
situation including by regulating and
prohibiting the use of property to fund
or support illegal blockades
finally
will enable the rcmp to enforce
municipal bylaws and provincial defenses
where required
this is what the emergencies act
does
that may be equally clear
about what it does not do
we're not using the emergencies act to
call in the military
we're not suspending fundamental rights
or overriding the charter of rights and
freedoms
we are not limiting people's freedom of
speech we are not limiting freedom of
peaceful assembly we are not preventing
people from exercising their right to
protest legally
we are reinforcing
the principles values and institutions
that keep all canadians
free
the emergencies act is not something
that's been used
ever
but it exists
for a reason
invoking the emergencies act
is never the first thing a government
should do nor even the second
the act is to be used sparingly
and as a last resort
right now
the situation requires additional tools
not held by any other federal provincial
or territorial law
today
in these circumstances it is now clear
that responsible leadership
requires us to do this
these measures must be and will be
compliant with our charter of rights and
freedoms indeed the emergencies act was
created in the late 80s to flow from and
uphold the charter
we'll always
defend the rights of canadians to
peaceful assembly and to freedom of
expression
but these blockades
are illegal
and if you're still participating
the time to go home
is now
on a separate track from the emergencies
act i want to reassure people that the
canadian border services agency is
already turning back non-canadians
trying to enter canada to participate in
blockades and of course while we get the
situation under control
we'll continue to have canadians backs i
want to remind affected businesses that
if you're facing revenue losses
support is available to our wage and
rent subsidy programs we know that
downtown ottawa businesses in particular
have been hard hit by these illegal
activities
in the coming days we'll be launching
specific support for those businesses
i know that everyone
is tired of this pandemic
we're hearing your frustration with
covid
and even with the temporary measures we
had to put forward to keep people safe
i know people are frustrated i hear it
you have a right to express that
frustration
and even your anger
with the government or government
policies
it's something we'll always defend in
this free and democratic country
but
blockading streets and critical
infrastructure and depriving your
neighbors of their freedoms
is a totally different thing
it has to stop
turmoil
everywhere other
measures
we will be making some announcements on
that subject in the coming days
today i also want to speak briefly
about our support for ukraine
on saturday
i spoke with president zielinski to
reaffirm canada's steadfast support
and to continue to do whatever we can to
support ukraine
as part of the collective g7 response to
support ukraine's economic resilience
today we're announcing that canada will
offer a loan of up to 500 million
dollars to the government of ukraine i
want to thank deputy prime minister
freeland for her leadership on this file
and underlying that this is in addition
to the 120 million dollar loan offered
earlier in january
on top of financial support canada has
already taken steps to help ukraine
defend itself including with the
extension of the training mission
operation unifier
in light of the seriousness of the
situation and following conversations
with our ukrainian partners
i've approved the provision of 7.8
million dollars worth of lethal
equipment and ammunition
this responds to ukraine's specific
request and is in addition to the
non-lethal equipment we've already
provided the intent of this support from
canada and other partners
is to deter
further russian aggression
situations
yes
but the situation is intensifying
rapidly
and we are showing our resolve
it's important for canadians and the
world to know that canada will continue
supporting ukraine and its independence
integrity
sovereignty
including its right to defend itself
merci tillman
thank you very much
i will now give the floor to deputy
prime minister freeland
[Music]
that this is not the case
these illegal barricades are doing great
damage to canada's economy
and to our reputation as a reliable
trading partner
the blockade of the ambassador bridge
has affected about
390 million dollars in trade
each day
this bridge supports 30 percent of all
trade
by road between canada and the united
states our most important trading
partner
in kutz alberta about 48 million dollars
in daily trade has been affected by the
blockades
in emerson manitoba about 73 million
dollars in daily trade has been affected
by the blockades
these costs are real
they threaten businesses big and small
and they threaten the livelihoods of
canadian workers
just as we are all working so hard
to recover from the economic damage
caused by covid
for protege
victories
as part of invoking the emergencies act
we are announcing the following
immediate actions
first we are broadening the scope of
canada's anti-money lauder laundering
and terrorist financing rules
so that they cover crowd funding
platforms
and the payment service providers they
use
these changes cover all forms of
transactions
including digital assets
such as crypto currencies
the illegal blockades have highlighted
the fact that crowdfunding platforms
and some of the payment service
providers they use
are not fully captured under the
proceeds of crime and terrorist
financing act
our banks and financial institutions are
already obligated to report to the
financial transactions and reports
analysis center of canada
or fintrac
as of today
all crowd funding platforms
and the payment service providers they
use
must register with fintrac
and they must report large and
suspicious transactions to fintrac
this will help mitigate the risk that
these platforms receive illicit funds
increase the quality and quantity of
intelligence received by fintrac
and make more information available to
support investigations by law
enforcement into these illegal blockades
we are making these changes because we
know that these platforms are being used
to support illegal blockades and illegal
activity which is damaging the canadian
economy
the government will also bring forward
legislation to provide these authorities
to fintrac on a permanent basis
second the government is issuing an
order with immediate effect
under the emergencies act
authorizing canadian financial
institutions to temporarily cease
providing financial services
where the institution suspects that an
account is being used to further the
illegal blockades and occupations
this order covers both personal
and corporate accounts
third we are directing canadian
financial institutions to review their
relationships with anyone involved in
the illegal blockades
and report to the rcmp
or thesis
as of today
a bank or other financial service
provider
will be able to immediately freeze or
suspend an account
without a court order
in doing so
they will be protected against civil
liability for actions taken in good
faith federal government institutions
will have a new broad authority to share
relevant information with banks and
other financial service providers
to ensure that we can all work together
to put a stop to the funding of these
illegal blockades
this is about
following the money
this is about stopping the financing of
these illegal blockades
we are today serving notice
if your truck is being used in these
illegal blockades
your corporate accounts will be frozen
the insurance on your vehicle will be
suspended
send your semi-trailers home
the canadian economy needs them to be
doing legitimate work
not to be illegally
making us all poorer
it's all about
finance
we have trusted one another
we've leaned on one another
what we are facing today is a threat to
our democratic institutions
to our economy
and to peace
order and good government in canada
this is unacceptable
it cannot stand
and it will not stand thank you and i'll
now turn over the floor to my colleague
or attorney general minister of justice
david
[Music]
thank you deputy prime minister
thank you prime minister colleagues
canadians
good afternoon
canada is a rule of law country
by declaring a public order emergency
under the emergencies act
we are following the law
and we are acting within it
there are clear conditions set out in
the emergencies act in order for a
public order emergency to be declared
our government believes that those
conditions have been met
and that requires the government of
canada to act
exists
the emergencies act can only be invoked
in specific serious circumstances that
amount to a national emergency
for a situation to be qualified as a
national emergency three conditions must
be met
first
we must be in a situation that either
seriously endangers lives health or
safety of canadians and exceeds the
capacity or authority of a province to
deal with it
or
seriously threatens the ability of the
government of canada to preserve the
sovereignty security and territorial
integrity of canada
second
the provinces and territories capacity
to handle the situation must be
considered insufficient or must show
gaps and third we must conclude that the
situation cannot be handled adequately
under any other canadian law including
provincial laws and territorial laws
essences
quickly and safely
the emergencies act also contains a
number of significant limits checks and
safeguards
as required by the act earlier today and
on occasion over the past week the prime
minister and members of cabinet have
consulted with premiers and members of
their respective governments
having now declared a public order
emergency we will table the declaration
in parliament as required within seven
days
in the coming days a parliamentary
committee will be struck to provide
oversight while the emergency is in
effect
the declaration
only lasts for 30 days unless renewed
however we can and sincerely hope to
revoke the emergency much sooner
parliament also has the ability to
revoke the declaration of the emergency
as set out clearly in the act
once an emergency is declared the
emergencies act permits the federal
government to make necessary orders or
regulations to deal with the emergency
the prime minister gave the broad
outline of these in his remarks
there are six specific measures we feel
are needed to bring this situation under
control
first the regulation and prohibition of
public assemblies that lead to a breach
of peace and go beyond lawful protest
what we are seeing in ottawa
and what we saw what we are seeing at
the ambassador bridge are not lawful
protests
second designating and securing places
where blockades are to be prohibited
this could include orders approaches to
borders and other critical
infrastructures or
ottawa
directing persons to render essential
services to relieve impacts of blockades
on canada's economy
and this could include tow trucks and
their drivers for compensation of course
authorizing or directing financial
institutions to render essential
services to relieve the impact of
blockades including as we have heard
from the deputy prime minister
regulating and prohibiting the use of
property to fund or support the
blockades
measures enabling the rcmp to enforce
municipal bylaws and provincial
offences where required
and finally the imposition of fines or
imprisonment for a contravention of any
more order
or regulation made under section 19 of
the emergencies act
they declared
these measures are temporary
we intend to impose them for only as
long as needed to restore order across
the country
thank you merci
thank you minister the prime minister
and ministers will be taking 30 minutes
of question starting in the foyer
starting with david thornton from cbc
hi prime minister a number of premiers
today have come out and said that they
don't want or need the federal
government to exercise its emergency
powers
in their provinces
so i'm just wondering how do you respond
to the premiers who've come out today
and said that
i thank the premiers for having had the
conversation with me this morning it was
extremely important to talk about what
was happening right across the country
we have seen
challenges uh across the country that
are
linked to
what we are seeing
here in ottawa what we're seeing at
border crossings
but allow me to repeat what i said
before
the measures brought in today are
geographically specific and targeted
only to where they are needed
these are not blanket powers across the
country
these will be tools that can be used
where and when necessary
so that the police of jurisdiction
dealing with
blockades or occupations
have the tools necessary and can draw on
rcmp resources as necessary
to keep canadians safe
to restore confidence
in the rule of law and in our
institutions and to make sure
that our economy continues to recover
from the impacts of covet 19 over the
past two years
at least one other premier said that
invoking this act is like putting oil on
a raging fire
words along those
lines do you think you're inflaming the
situation even more by invoking this
my focus is on canadians
who've had a long two years
who've been through a pandemic who've
lost loved ones
who've seen businesses struggle
lost jobs
and just want this to be over
they're exhausted we're all exhausted
we're all frustrated by the pandemic
but those people who disagree
with the measures that governments put
in place
to keep canadians safe to ensure that we
would make it through this pandemic
better than many of our peer countries
those people have gone from
protesting
and disagreeing with those measures
to limiting
and blocking
the freedoms of their fellow citizens
hurting jobs
hurting lives and livelihoods
endangering public safety
and weakening our country not just right
now
but
for times to come in the eyes of our
most important trading partners
these legal blockades are hurting
canadians and they need to stop
every step of the way
we have been there to support the police
of jurisdiction
we've been there
with tools and resources to help end
these blockades
but it is clear that there are more
tools necessary
and that is why we are moving forward
with time limited
geographically specific
extremely bounded measures and
additional powers
that will allow us to get through
these blockades and occupations and get
back to the business of rebuilding our
lives
and our country
after this pandemic next question
is canada
foreign
and
and we even
will not
on a national level
all canadians
is necessary
in the third week yeah
we were
and in the last few days
you mentioned that the rcmp now have the
ability to enforce provincial and
municipal laws does that mean that
they'll be the lead police force agency
here in ottawa and when can we expect
more police officers from the rcmp to
work with the city of ottawa because
they've been asking for that for a
substantial period of time
um
as i said the invocation of the
emergencies act
gives more power to the police of
jurisdiction it does not
make the rcmp automatically police of
jurisdiction anywhere across the country
as we have been
we will ensure that the rcmp continues
to work to support
local police of jurisdiction
and that's what we have been doing in
ottawa but i think on this question i'm
happy to turn to minister mendocino who
can give
further
further information on uh on the
situation in ottawa marco
yeah
thanks very much uh prime minister
um
from the very beginning of the uh
illegal blockades the federal government
has been working closely with
local law enforcement uh where they are
the police of jurisdiction including
here in ottawa i would point out uh that
we've sent three um
install installments of reinforcements
to ensure that
that ottawa police service has
the support they need
but i think as we've seen without
question there have been many many
challenges
on the ground to restoring public order
on the streets and one only has to look
at the situation on wellington street
over the past number of weekends
i think it's difficult to overstate
the impact of those scenes the conduct
that has uh that has unfolded by those
who are participating in illegal
blockades
it is not just an inconvenience
it is not simply a matter of
a trivial interruption we've seen
intimidation harassment
and expressions of hate
and at times
the scenes on the streets of wellington
have seemed
completely lawless
and that is one of the reasons why
we've had to take
the very careful and deliberate step
of introducing the emergency
emergencies act today and the
declaration and the specific
powers which again
are very targeted they're very
proportionate and they're time limited
so that there can be greater agility
between the rcmp who will work
seamlessly with um local law enforcement
including in in ottawa uh to to restore
order
um i would also say that while we have
seen progress for example in windsor
that we should not assume that that
progress is linear
and that is one of the reasons why these
measures through the declaration are
also necessary
we want to be certain that
local law enforcement has
uh the the concrete tools that they need
for example tow trucks which have been
very hard to come by um in addition to
that the kind of jersey barriers which
will assist uh with with crowd control
that will ensure that trade and traffic
can move very efficiently
and in addition to that when it comes to
the the relationship between the rcmp
and local law enforcement and provincial
enforcement
the provision that is within the
declaration
will allow the rcmp uh to be more
efficiently um assigned to those areas
to uphold the law be they municipal laws
provincial laws
or indeed um the the designated zones
which will be prohibited from assembly
because they may cause a breach of peace
or may uh interrupt our critical
infrastructure through trade so when you
look at the suite of the measures that
we put into place today and we've
certainly put a lot of thought into that
our view is that
they are necessary and they will assist
us in dealing with the illegal blockades
and bringing them to a peaceful and
expeditious resolution
as my follow-up mr trudeau mr mendocino
just mentioned that when you look out on
wellington street here you see lawless
scenes
why do you have any faith that the
ottawa police after three weeks now is
going to be able to turn things around
and restore law and order in this area
um
in regards to the ottawa police we have
been working closely
not just the rcmp but
the opp
to ensure that there is a coordinated
approach on that but
in terms of confidence in the police i
think we could do worse than turn to
our minister of emergency preparedness
bill blair
to respond to that bill
thank you very much prime minister and
good afternoon everyone
um
the the rcm excuse me the ontario ottawa
police service remains the police of
jurisdiction in the city of ottawa
but the the police services right across
canada and certainly in ontario have
been coming together and they recently
announced on friday the the formation of
an integrated um command structure for
the for managing this event and then
that really brings the resources and the
capacities of the opp and the rcmp to
the assistance of the ottawa police uh
we've also had conversations with other
police agencies across ontario and and
they recognize the situation here and
the importance of of ensuring that there
are adequate resources but it's it's not
simply an issue of resources but also of
authorities and we have been working
from the very outset with with the
municipality and with the province in
order to ensure that our police services
here in ottawa and right across canada
have the authorities they need and and
the resources they need to do the
important job now as i said yesterday
policing is a very important institution
in our society we need the police to do
their job of upholding our laws to
maintain the rule of law and to maintain
public order and safety in our
communities and we have a responsibility
to make sure that they have the
resources and the tools that they need
to do that job they have our support and
and and as as that support uh grows in
in the city of ottawa i have confidence
that they'll be able to restore order
with the support that we're providing
next question
hi prime minister stephanie taylor with
the canadian press you emphasized we're
not calling in the military to deal with
the situation but all options as you
said last week are on the table so what
would it take for you to bring the
military into this situation what would
the criteria be and what would it take
for you to make that decision um i'm not
going to engage in hypotheticals right
now i think what is most important is
that canadians get their lives back
their communities back their
neighborhoods back
and can once again rely on their jobs
and the trade and the supply chains that
are supporting them and putting food on
their tables
the reality is the measures that we put
forward today
which have been carefully thought
through
will give the tools to law enforcement
to be able to move
in
even
stronger and clearer ways
against these illegal protests these
legal occupations
and blockades
that are hurting canadians
we will continue
to monitor and we will continue to do
the things necessary to keep canadians
safe but like i said
this emergencies act in no way
brings in the military as a solution
against canadians we are empowering law
enforcement i think that's what
canadians want to see
over the weekend minister blair
expressed that he was a little baffled
by the lack of law enforcement he saw i
want to know what you think do you agree
with him
or the laws what do you make of the
policing you have seen to date on
wellington street and elsewhere in
ottawa i think there are
there is a high level of frustration
amongst uh residents of ottawa uh that
this situation has gone on as long as it
has
certainly the uh frustration people feel
in ottawa has been echoed across the
country
and indeed around the world
and it is important that
the police of jurisdiction working with
the opp and the rcmp
are able to put an end to these illegal
protests the
specific and limited measures that we
are putting forward today as part of the
emergencies act will give them further
tools
coordinated response between the ottawa
police services the opp and the rcmp
working together um should be able to uh
respond to these concerns by the
citizens of ottawa who want their cities
back we'll take one last question in the
fight before turning to the phone
yeah uh prime minister ryan timothy
national post uh over the weekend mayor
jim watson here in ottawa made a deal
with protest organizers to move more
trucks onto wellington street and out of
residential areas i'm wondering if you
can give any reaction to that deal
i know that the city of ottawa its
police services and its elected
officials have been pursuing an end to
these blockades
this has gone on far too long it is no
longer a lawful protest
at a disagreement over government policy
it is now an illegal occupation it's
time for people to go home the measures
that we've put forward today will be
additional tools for law enforcement at
all levels
to be able to
secure an end to these blockades
you're announcing today rules around
preventing banks from dealing with these
illegal blockades the city of ottawa has
dealt with these legal blockades don't
you find that problematic that they have
cut a deal to put more trucks directly
in front of parliament hill
we are working
in a concerted way
on measures that will hopefully restore
order to the city of ottawa and allow
residents to get back to their lives the
measures that we put forward today
around
empowering banks
to follow up
and to
ensure that funds are not used for
illegal activities such as blockades
will be significantly helpful
in um in reducing the size and impact of
these blockades
please press star one at this time if
you have a question
the first question will be from the
premier question
please go ahead
uh
immediately
and what we are now
lollies and people continue to be there
for one another
by these blockades
uh
those people
oh
use illegal means to protest thank you
merci
the next question is from la prochaine
question
charles toronto
uh thank you um prime minister i didn't
hear um an answer about the to the
question mack asked about reinforcements
from the rcmp to the city of ottawa and
if you can answer that great but
how specifically do you justify giving
even more powers to police in ottawa
when many residents and policing experts
say the law enforcement here has not
used the power they already have under
existing laws that this is a failure of
policing leadership not
the need for more power
later to reflect on
all the lessons that can be learned from
this situation
right now we are ensuring uh that local
police of jurisdiction have
both the legal authorities that they
need
to
do their jobs but also the extra
resources we have
delivered
not just
rcmp officers as the opp has delivered
opp officers to support the city of
ottawa
but we've also provided integrated
planning and coordination task force to
ensure that we are able to actually see
an end to this occupation of ottawa
following up
um
yes i'd like you to speak if you could
you mentioned as did minister freeland
um
the reputational damage to the country
that you feel the border protests have
had and the
impact on canada's
i guess reputation as a reliable trading
partner but can you speak a little bit
more about just
what was the tipping point for you in
all of this was it really the fact that
the white house has been weighing in and
burning up the phone lines all weekend
to all your ministers really why have
you moved to do this
uh
for me
the conversations i had with our windsor
mp here at kasmerchik who was talking
about
the impact of the disruption of the
ambassador bridge
almost as soon as it started happening
the impact on uh
workers in the auto sector in the
windsor area and up the supply chain
through southern ontario
the direct impact hurting
exactly the people that
these
convoy protesters are purporting
to represent
regular canadians are hurting in their
jobs
in our economic recovery
in their freedoms to travel to see
friends and loved ones on the other side
of the border
because of illegal protests and
barricades
we have been there to support
local polices of jurisdiction
and we are now putting forward fresh
tools to do that
in terms of the reputational damage in
my conversations with fellow leaders
around the world on the situation in
ukraine and others
it has been clear that this is something
that democracies around the world are
concerned with
countries that did well
during the pandemic with high
vaccination rates and strong public
health measures
are still seeing
backlashes against those measures
and
frustration by people who are tired of
this pandemic
and the
impact of
social media and
illicit funding
of
concerted activities designed to
destabilize a country
that has the highest vaccination rate of
many of our peer countries canada
around an issue that is not dividing
canadians canadians are united in having
been there for each other through this
pandemic and they're even united in
being sick and tired of this pandemic
but the way to get through it
is not to shut down our economy and hurt
our neighbors
and that's something that
people understand around the world
and with this measure here today showing
that canada remains
a country of the rule of law
that will protect its critical
infrastructure
that will support
good jobs
that deliver
deliver goods and services not just to
canadians to people around the world
are going to be protected
operator next question thank you merci
the next question is from la prochaine
boris
please go ahead please
i'm very pleased to hand the floor to mr
lamity to answer that question
minister lamented
is
[Music]
um
um
uh
we cannot do so through provincial
legislation
we are using ministry questions
uh
one last question on the telephone
thank you mercedes
canada these rooms fly across canada
oh
is
and that is not everywhere in canada of
course
thank you merci the last question is
from la daniel question
marieke walsh the globe and male please
go ahead as
parallel afternoon prime minister
minister lemaitre if i understood him
said that this will apply across canada
and that provinces will not be able to
opt out your opening statement said that
this would be geographically targeted so
can you please explain where
specifically in canada this will apply
i i actually just answered that in
french and i'm happy to repeat it
because it is an important point that
people need to understand
the emergency measures act as it is
applied when it is a national emergency
that touches more than one province as
this one is
necessarily
covers the entire country because it is
a federal national emergencies act
however
the specific provisions that we have
laid out in the act
the measures necessary
will only apply
where they are needed
we talked about geographically limited
obviously uh to con continue to ensure
that the ambassador bridge remains free
and clear for traffic
that is a place where uh the measures
brought in by this emergencies act
will matter
uh a
small community elsewhere in the country
a long way from borders or critical
infrastructure that is not experiencing
uh any uh yet significant illegal
protests
are unlikely to see any impact from
these uh
uh emergency
uh the emergency act
this this is the element that is limited
to where it is needed and indeed in
places where there is a significant
border crossing where the local police
of jurisdiction
have no need of additional
rcmp support or even the additional
tools that we have made available to
them
they will not have to use
those additional tools
so even though the emergencies act
applies to the entire country
it is targeted time limited and
geographically specific based on
need
as to where it will actually be felt and
have an impact on the ground
following up
thank you so can you please clarify then
will it apply in emerson manitoba coupe
alberta and surrey bc
and how will you measure the success of
this that this is not just your
government appearing to do something but
that actual results happen
well i think canadians know well that
the measure of success will be
can we get our supply chains back can we
get uh end the disruption to livelihoods
of people who rely on trade to the
united states from these border
crossings can the citizens of ottawa get
back to their daily lives
including as we saw just a few weeks ago
when a perfectly peaceful protest
involving tractors and trucks of
potatoes from pei were on parliament
hill highlighting their cons that is how
this country
how protests can
unfold
but this
illegal
and that is
we have now given specific tools
necessary for that
in regards to
emerson and cootes
one of the issues that we have seen is a
challenge in
getting tow trucks to actually show up
to
bring out to to move
these large rigs
in
in windsor
we relied on
this partnership with the americans
to be able to get tow trucks to move the
big trucks
um
now with these
measures that we've put in place
there will be an ability to compel
for just compensation
tow truck owners and operators to
actually do the jobs for which they have
contracts with various orders of
government to keep highways and roads
clear
this is an example of a specific tool
that is now available
to local police of jurisdiction in
places all across the country if needed
it would be to them to determine whether
or not that is
today's press needed to an end thank you
everyone
you